SEND IT BACK TO YOU, BRIAN.
BRIAN: NUTS.
WALLS WORK.
DHS CHIEF SECRETARY I SHOULD SAY
MAYORKAS IS REPORTEDLY
CONSIDERING RESTARTING BORDER
WALL CONSTRUCTION IN ORDER TO
FILL IN GAPS MADE OBVIOUS BY
PEOPLE WITH VISION WHO ALSO
NOTICED ILLEGALS WALKING THROUGH
THESE GAPS.
OUR NEXT GUEST WARNS THE CRISIS
DOESN’T STOP AT THE BORDER.
IT FILTERS INTO EVERY COMMUNITY
IN OUR COUNTRY.
LIVINGSTON COUNTY ILLINOIS
SHERIFF TONY CHILDRESS JOINS US
NOW.
HOW DO YOU FEEL THIS IN
ILLINOIS, SHERIFF?
, GOOD MORNING, BRIAN, AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME.
WE FEEL THIS IN ILLINOIS BY WAY
OF THE, I WOULD SAY, THE
HIGHWAYS AND THE BYWAYS.
WE HAVE INTERSTATE 55 THAT ARE
UPS RIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE OF OUR
COUNTY FOR 31 MILES.
SO, WE ARE 90 MILES SOUTH OF
CHICAGO.
SO, INTERSTATE 55 IS A MAIN
THOROUGHFARE FROM CHICAGO TO
MEXICO IT.
RUNS AS YOU KNOW THERE CHICAGO
TO LOUISIANA IT IS A HEAVILY
TRAVELED ROUTE FOR DRUG
TRAFFICKERS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS.
BRIAN: I WAS WATCHING THIS ON
ANOTHER CHANNEL HE A HE CAME OUT
AND SAID DO THE RIGHT THING.
TAKE 5,000 ILLEGAL KIDS.
REALLY?
ARE WE OUT OF KIDS THAT NEED
HELP ALL THE FOSTER CARE HOMES
KIDS ALREADY ACCOUNTED FOR?
IT JUST MAKES NO SENSE.
HERE IS WHAT THE DHS SECRETARY
WILL MAYORKAS SAID REPORTEDLY
SPOKE TO ICE OFFICIALS LAST
GHEEK A VIRTUAL MEETING.
SAID THIS:
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE HIM FILL
THE GAPS IN THESE WALLS, PUT THE
TECHNOLOGY IN, AND FINISH OF THE
ROADS.
>> ABSOLUTELY, BRIAN.
WHO LEAVES THEIR DOORS UNLOCKED
AT NIGHT WHEN THEY GO TO SLEEP.
BRIAN: NO ONE.
>> AND WHEN THEY LEAVE TO GO TO
WORK?
WHO LEAVES THEIR DOORS UNLOCKED?
I DON’T KNOW ANYBODY WHO DOES
THAT WHY WOULD WE LEAVE OUR
NATION OPEN FOR IMMIGRANTS TO
COME IN, MANY OF THEM, I’M NOT
SAYING ALL OF THEM, BUT MANY OF
THEM ARE CRIMINALS.
WHY WOULD YOU LEAVE YOUR NATION
UNLOCKED SO IT LEAVES OUR PUBLIC
UNSAFE?
UNSAFE.
IS SO, NO.
LISTEN, IF THEY ARE GOING TO BE
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS AND BE
TRUTHFUL ABOUT FILLING IN THOSE
GAPS IN THOSE WALLS, I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE IT.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND I WOULD SUPPORT THAT 1,000%.
BRIAN: I WANT YOU TO SEE THIS
FULL SCREEN I DON’T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE A MONITOR THERE.
LET’S GO TO THIS.
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER ENCOUNTERS
IN MARCH OF 2018 THERE WERE
50,000.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A LOT.
2019103, THAT SEEMS LIKE A LOT.
GOT AHOLD OF THIS LAST YEAR GOT
IT DOWN TO 34,000.
GUESS WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW IN
MARCH, WE THINK ROUGHLY 171,000.
WHERE ARE WE GOING TO PUT ALL
THESE PEOPLE?
THEY MIGHT BE GREAT PEOPLE WE
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT IT.
AND SHERIFF, I DON’T KNOW IF YOU
HEARD, WE ARE IN A PANDEMIC.
THEY ARE GOING IN.
THEY HAVE INSPECTORS RAIDING
KITCHENS IN RESTAURANTS MAKING
SURE COOKS WEAR MASKS SO THEY
GET HUGE FINES, BUT IT’S OKAY TO
LEE OUR WHOLE BACK DOOR OPEN TO
LET OTHER COUNTRIES TO COME IN
UNTESTED, SOME DON’T EVEN GET
SCREENED WITH A COURT ORDER TO
APPEAR BACK TO CHECK ON THEIR
STATUS.
YOUR THOUGHT ON THAT?
>> WELL, BRIAN, I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT, LISTEN, THAT DEFIES ALL
PURE LOGIC.
OKAY?
THERE IS NO GOOD REASON OR
THINKING THAT GOES INTO LEAVING
OUR DOORS UP LOCKED AND LEAVING
OUR NATION UNSECURED.
BRIAN: IF YOU BRING STUFF LIKE
THAT UP, THEY THINK THAT’S
UNAMERICAN, I DON’T THINK IT’S
UNAMERICAN LOOKING OUT FOR
AMERICANS FIRST.
SHERIFF TONY CHILDRESS, YOU HAVE
YOUR HANDS FULL.